now get ready because this one is all
about cooking for special occasions when
you're cooking for a special occasion
you want to nail some key things one
your recipes need to be bulletproof you
don't want a disaster on the big day -
as well as tasting phenomenal they have
to be easy to serve so you can relax and
enjoy yourself
3 when you're out to impress food needs
to look great - my first recipe fits the
bill perfectly stuffed lamb with spinach
and pine nuts stuff meats are perfect
for special occasions they look
impressive tastes amazing but more
importantly they are so simple to do
panel for something it's a saddle of
lamb basically a sort of Rolls Royce cut
perfectly shaped and it suits stuffing
to an absolute tea for the stuffing
finely chop an onion garlic nice thin
slices oil in onions and garlic in it's
a salt and pepper make sure the stuffing
is beefy season so it helps to season
the inside of the lamb now we've got a
color on those onions when we throw in
some pine nuts and that helps to give a
bit of a texture
his voice starts getting really exciting
spinach in and just lay the spinach over
the pine nuts it looks like a lot of
spinach that's gonna condense and
disappear almost instantly so much more
flavor and spin is when you slow to it
as opposed to steaming it or boiling you
gas off and look around now to bring
that together no eggs no breadcrumbs
crumbled feta over the spinach feta
cheese adds a beauty salty sharp and
creamy flavor
what this does it brings that stuffing
together now open up the lamb keep
there's little Phyllis to the side
that's the channel that we want to
stuffed I wanna just open that up a
little bit there salt and pepper
lightly and before would we're stuffing
in we're season it with soon sumac is a
wonderful lemony spice that goes
brilliantly with lamb and you can get it
in most big supermarkets and it sort of
cuts through that thick rich sweetness
of the lamb open up that lamb there take
a spoon if you're preparing this for the
day ahead then let the stuffing cool
down it's inevitable when you start
rolling it and tying it somes gonna
squeeze out so load up the ends take
these beauties these little Phillips and
just support that stuffing and sort of
increase that beautiful tunnel and then
from there over there and bring that
towards you and then roll like I said so
much stuff is gonna come out now they're
tight
first off around the side and don't
worry about some flash which is not just
tie one in the middle
you can get butchers drink from your
local butcher or cookware shops I got
two ties go to tie it just forces all
that stuffing out of the lamb when it's
in the oven nice now we'll just season
the top of it roll the joint to make
sure all the skin gets seasoned now you
think normally that just goes in the
oven like that that's how my mum would
do it but get you tray onto the gas oil
in get it really nicely colored nothing
of stuffing is coming out of the sides
really important
look at that color beautiful does
kickstart a roasting process gas off
into the oven cook for 45 to 55 minutes
depending on how pink you want your lamp
lift the lamb out of the fat to rest
resting it raised up in the tin we'll
stop it cooking but not cool it down too
quickly that means you won't lose any of
those lovely juices next I'm making a
simple but sophisticated accompaniment
for the lamb top and tail the cucumber
peel it cut the cucumber into three and
just core take it out all that it's just
sort of water ECD and it spoils the
flavor slice cucumber cucumber in a
really nice way of making a cheap and
cheerful cucumber look glamorous we're
gonna dress that cucumber with a nice
fresh yogurt with tablespoons next it's
a fresh mint dressing touch a salt touch
of pepper and then pomegranate molasses
that just swings it up finish that with
lemon mix that up
laughs its rested carefully take off the
string and then just gently pull them
back straight edge edge knife that's
going to cut through that crispy foul on
the outside instantly I tied it
purposely so I can get my portion
control from the lines hold it nice and
firmly look at your line where the
string was and look this one is gonna be
amazing
lay and down just in those two slices
there
it proves that stuffing meats is for
special occasions because that is a
saddle of lamb at its absolute best
stuffing meats and fish not only makes
them look fantastic it also gives them
an extra added flavor dimension to once
you've mastered the technique you'll be
able to turn out dishes that will
guarantee they'll have an unforgettable
feast here are three more of my favorite
easy stuff dishes that are perfect for
any feast first up chicken with garlic
and chestnut stuffing pack with flavor
and earthy richness
[Music]
for the stuffing fry finely chopped
onion garlic and celery in hot olive oil
next add pine nuts which have a lovely
creamy taste and chopped earthy cooked
chestnuts both at a wonderfully chewy
texture and richness to stuffings season
and add chopped parsley
[Music]
then stirring cooked wild rice next take
a whole deboned chicken it's fitting to
do at home but if you ask your butcher
will do for you and pile the stuffing
mixture along the center now simply roll
the chicken off tightly and tie it with
your butcher string
then roast in a hot oven for just over
an hour
simply carve into magnificent bigger
slices it's so impressive or so easy
and trust me this is a dish guaranteed
to get a fantastic reaction on any
occasion whole stuffed fish will always
make an impression my next recipe is sea
bass stuffed with fennel lemon and
capers
first place a whole gutted sea bass on
foil and seasoned the fish inside and
out sea bass is known as the king of the
Seas and as a wonderful sweet white
flesh start the stuffing with sliced
fennel its aniseed flavor works
brilliantly with the fish next and
capers a fresh dill and slices of lemon
then dotting knobs of butter lastly add
a splash of white wine which helps to
steam the fish and create a lovely sauce
and fill tightly into a parcel this lot
of all the juices and flavor and simply
bake and a media mother unwrapped and
here your guests boom and are with
delight prepared in 10 minutes
rat for intense flavor a stunning sea
bass that's bound to create a stir
my next dish throws a Spanish twist on a
classic English roast pork stuffed with
Manchego and men brillo use a pork loin
roasting joint later join skin side down
I've got 3/4 of the way into the flesh
creating space for stuffing next thinly
sliced Spanish manchego cheese this has
a wonderful buttery nutty taste and is
fantastic for stuffing as it melds
brilliantly sliced Spanish membrillo
quince jelly sweet and perfumed is the
perfect partner for the saltiness of the
cheese then simply layer your cheese and
quince jelly into the pork
at Sage leaves for strong and
deliciously bitter flavor roll the meat
up and tie with butcher string next have
more sage leaves and some aromatic fresh
thyme to a roasting tin then lay the
pork on top skin side up cut a bulb of
garlic in half and wedge it under the
meat the garlic wedges help lit the port
to roast to perfection all had a sweet
death of flavor to your gravy drizzle
with olive oil seasoned and roast for
just over an hour with the heat on high
for the first 20 which helps get the
skin crispy and golden
once cooked leave the port to rest as
you make a stunning gravy
simply place the roasting tin over
medium heat as a glug of sherry and
delays using the roasting juices gives
your gravy maximum flavor
simmer and reduce for a few minutes then
pour in incredible resting juices from
the pork
finally strain the silky rich gravy over
the step loin and serve immediately
stuff through with incredible flavor
rich sweet and aromatic a stunning
centerpiece fit to grace any table
anywhere anytime three dishes stuff to
perfection true you can have food that's
simple to pull off but looks incredible
and tastes a million bucks amazing to
make these recipes
you only need to rely on two basic
pieces of kit don't need to spend a
fortune on masses of kitchen equipments
roasting and baking tray these things so
versatile great for baking whole fish on
fantastic for making breads and so cheap
a classic to handle roasting tray
brilliant for roasting hot birds
finishing sauces gravies on top of the
stove over the gas ring burner again
versatile the more solid your trays are
the better then they weren't buckled and
they will last cheap but seriously
essential
this is my optima cookery course a
hundred recipes to stake your life on
I'll be teaching you how to grab your
guests attention with an amazingly easy
but stunning starter good news about
these wraps is that you can make them up
in advance but first my guide to getting
the best ingredients for your money when
you're cooking needs to impress it
really pays to spend extra time shopping
for great ingredients and you reap the
rewards when it's time to serve next up
my guide to find the finest shellfish
[Applause]
whether it's scallops prawns crabs or
Lobster spanking fresh shellfish never
fails to make an impression and when you
want the best crustaceans it pays to ask
an expert
now I'm clean bad it's a bargain at 20
pound fishmonger Roger Barton really
knows his shellfish inside out hello you
see Cuddy go back out so I'm sorry Brad
you're with me he's been in the fish
game at London's billa's gang market for
over 35 years
lean some of his knowledge and you'll
never be at a loss when it comes to
shopping for shellfish
right what we've got here are Corvettes
some people known as prongs and these
are a picture they've got to be lovely
and shiny you'll find if they're tuned
in the head starts coming away from the
body not a good sign
looks a bit like me worse for the way
chop your garlic up get the old watt
lovely bit of olive oil
lovely lovely EE lovely lovely jubbly in
they go absolutely fantastic and if you
like prawns as much as me then you'll
love all these different kinds here are
my favourites Brown shrimps might be
tiny but punch well above their weight
in terms of taste I love them potted in
spiced butter and spread on toast
Atlantic prawns a great value and packed
with flavor fantastic as tapas or in
curries
small tiger prawns are also good value
and great for Asian salads stir fries
and fish juice whereas these massive
ones are so spectacular I just keep them
simple marinated in garlic oil and chili
char grilled and served in their shells
and longest things are one of my
favorites
you can buy these subtle and beauties
whole just roast or boil and serve with
garlic mayonnaise people used to eat
winkles cockles they're not doing it
anymore it's such a shame they should be
more daring all due respect you wouldn't
make love the same way for the rest of
your life
wrinkles there they are lovely they
smell of the sea little bit of pepper
and salt and a dash of vinegar then that
does enhance the flavor in this country
we have got the finest oysters in the
world
oh I'd die for these the only thing you
have to look for with an oyster that is
tightly closed if it's open avoid being
dangerous come on try nothing ventured
nothing gained get the right recipe and
the freshest shellfish and you're
guaranteed success in the kitchen
whether it's in one of my restaurants or
back at home I know that as well as
delicious food one of the fundamentals
to making guests happy is creating a
great atmosphere so my next recipe where
guests get to eat with their hands is
perfect for a special occasion
Vietnamese style fresh corn rolls one of
the keys to cooking for crowds is
creating an atmosphere and that buzz
getting your guests to sort of almost
get involved and dip in and dip out this
is an exciting fragrant wrap that is so
easy to do
first off soak the noodles these are
thin glass noodles basically bring the
kettle up at the boil and just pour just
let them steep there for a couple
minutes the noodles are for my porn
rolls and they soak I'm gonna make a
spicy dipping sauce to go with them
start off with sugar we're trying to
create that sweet sour salty but a real
nice sort of heated sauce as well rice
wine vinegar that will dissolve a sugar
fish sauce now that's gonna give it a
saltiness next the chili
I want the seeds left in because I want
some power chili in a little bit of
garlic don't need to chop it too finely
just slice it take a spring onion just
top and tell them slice slice is
bringing it nice and thinly so it's sort
of almost permeating start dipping sauce
I grew up with the love of spring rolls
but on the back of my visit to Vietnam
it sort of transformed my respect for a
spring roll give that a little mix a
little bit of coriander and fresh mint
roll them up and chopped herbs in
there's no olive all in there is no
cream is no butter so it's a really nice
light dipping sauce and Wow
all those sensors going on now we're
gonna make the filling for the wraps a
really nice fresh noodle salad
bring the noodles in cold water then
chop them into bite-sized lengths
claud's peeled and cooked sai-sama
the prawns give a really nice sweetness
next the vegetables I want crunch
freshness texture baby gem lettuce I
just shred that lettuce next spring
onion the good news about these wraps is
that you can make them up in advance sit
them in the fridge and then take them
out literally seconds before you guess
arrive till the care so you got a really
nice fresh crunchy carrot now fresh mint
fresh basil and fresh coriander together
it sounds a little bit bizarre but
tastes amazing don't hold back with the
herbs they'll really help make the
filling vibrant fresh and aromatic
finally such a large to squeeze that
fresh lime juice over there couple of
tablespoons of your dipping sauce don't
put too much in there just makes all the
filling too wet just give that a really
good mix that's a very quick simple
salad to eat now but let's get it into a
wrap
now take your rice paper wrap literally
30 seconds in warm water you can get
rice paper wraps from your local Asian
supermarket or buy them online
gently lift it out of the water
beautiful lay it carefully onto your
board place the mixture at the bottom
don't overfill it because be a nightmare
to raw fold them over first nice and
tightly halfway and tuck in the ends
make sure nothing's coming out the sides
beautiful it's a light fragrant
incredibly simple to do and there you go
a very delicious fragrant Asian wrap
certainly different the Chinese spring
rolls I grew up with
next five more of my 100 tips to help
your special occasion cooking better
kicking off with how to prepare for
prawns
to prep it get the head and twist keep
all of those heads make the most amazing
stock and then with your thumb get
underneath the shell and just peel off a
beautiful little layer now with your
thumb when your finger push and shake
and look the whole tail comes off and
you have to peel the whole thing from
there get your knife and just gently cut
the surface of the prawn and what we're
looking for there is that little dirt
sack that's got to come out otherwise if
you cook the problem with that sack in
there it's crunchy it's not very nice
and it ruins that sweet flavor and there
you go the most amazing prawn ready for
cooking serving hot fish always makes an
impact here's how to fill it it at the
table
run a knife along the backbone remove
the skin and carefully lift off the
portions of flesh using a fish slice
then just lift off the backbone in one
careful movement
whole hams are always impressive to
carve one easily pulled down by the bone
and cut down the meat as close to the
bone as possible
you could then lay your cut ham flat on
the board making it nice and easy to
slice thinly and evenly for perfect pork
crackling pour over hot oil before
roasting in the oven they'll come out
beautifully crisp and crunchy and when
you need to chill wine fast simply add a
large handful of salt to your ice bucket
the salt reduces the freezing point of
the water which will kill your wine in a
6 minutes flat follow my ultimate
cookery course crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the App Store for
details go on get cooking